thank you for that well a trip to the
arts district in downtown las vegas will
soon cost you a little more the city is
set to install parking meters at the end
of this month rates will vary between a
dollar or two an hour now you can see
the impacted areas highlighted in pink
green and yellow right there on the map
joe muller joining us live there with
what people are saying about this joe
christian well you know when you come
down here and it's during the busy hours
it's not necessarily easy to park but
right now it is free you just pull up
get out of your car and walk around
people we talked to who work down here
say they're happy with the idea of any
parking meters to pay for a parking
garage others were not too thrilled
about the idea
soon there will be 64 meters with
monthly rates available for employees
the money will go towards a new parking
garage you will be able to pay using a
debit or credit card those who work in
the arts district say it will be worth
it in the long run and make more spaces
available as they are metered it'd
probably be a good idea just because
then we'd be able to find parking or
even if we're able to
pay for our parking i wouldn't mind
because at least i'd be able to come to
work on time art district regulars
gordon vallo and kate dessa weren't too
thrilled to hear about the meters it
makes the area feel a little bit more
inviting you know when you just can
stroll in and cruise into a spot not to
worry about having the right change on
you or forgetting to pay or you know
worrying about getting a ticket and that
kind of thing so you know it's a little
bit of a bummer but it's not going to
stop you from coming
another live look here at main street in
the arts district well there already are
meters in downtown near fremont street
they start to go in here in the our
district at the end of the month now the
city says
the location for that parking garage is
not set but they have expect
construction to be underway by 2024.
reporting in the arts district this
evening joe muller live